un site internet en guise de prise de
température avec une question qui brûle
les lèvres de nombreux touristes mais
aussi des citoyens et des politiques à
vaccin sera-t-il obligatoire pour
voyager voir se rendre dans des lieux
clos favorable défavorable mitigé les
internautes ont jusqu'au 7 mars pour
donner leur avis ni consultation
citoyenne organisée par le conseil
économique social et environnemental à
laquelle l'exécutif pourrait être
sensible le fait de conditionner le
déplacement au fait d'être vacciné est
un sujet éthique et pas un petit sujet
un gouvernement qu'ils jugent pour
l'heure le débat autour du passeport
vaccinale prématuré objectif premier
faciliter toutes les démarches de tests
avant et après un voyage pour l'heure
aucun consensus ne s'est dégagé au sein
de la majorité
le jour où 20% de la population
française refusera de se faire vacciner
il faudra qu'ils assument quand tous nos
voisins européens lors ont mis en place
on n'aura pas le choix pour voyager et
éviter les quarantaine
[Musique]
le 7 février dernier dans les rues de
copenhague des centaines de danois ont
manifesté contre les dernières mesures
sanitaires mais aussi contre l'idée d'un
futur passeport numérique vaccinale un
débat prématuré pour la france mais pas
pour ses partenaires européens
parmi ceux ci les gouvernements
espagnols autrichien ou encore suédois
se sont déclarés favorables et
discussions sont en cours au sein des
états européens et de l'om s nous
travaillons ici à l'élaboration de
normes internationales afin de pouvoir
faire confiance à ce certificat
ce que nous en suède aimerions faire
nous ne voulons pas d'un morceau de
papier avec un cachet que nous ne
comprenons pas si vous êtes un pays qui
dit que vous ne pouvait venir que si
vous avez été vaccinées vous voulez être
sûr qu'une personne qui dit avoir été
vaccinés a été vaccinée et nous voulons
que les britanniques puissent se rendre
dans ces pays et donc qu'ils puissent
démontrer leur statut vaccinal autres
possibilités des négociations de pays à
pays la grèce et chypre ont passé un
accord avec israël pour permettre aux
ressortissants vacciner des trois pays
de voyager sans contraintes ni
quarantaine